[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of x directed by ty west
so it's always exciting when a 24 comes
out of the horror they haven't actually
come out with many slasher films so i
was excited to see what this film would
be like with that mix of a24 and slasher
and having ty west on board here and
there's a lot of mixed feelings i have
about this film but mostly good
i think that it's really
so
awesome to see these three female leads
just
totally own this film and i've
was so impressed by how good all three
of them are and that's mia goth britney
snow and jenna ortega and the thing is
that it's blew my mind i didn't even
know while watching it that miyagatha
was playing pearl the old woman as well
as playing maxine so that's really cool
to see and she did a great job i've
never seen her or anything before so
it's always exciting also i always
praise jenna ortega anything i review
with her in it and
you know i always saw that she's on the
rise fast right it's pretty unanimous
she's a great actress but this
just sealed the deal for me like this
woman is going to be
a superstar and the moment i realized
that was when she did her first scream
when she saw the body in the basement
that
blew my mind how good that was and i was
like okay she's gonna win an oscar one
day it's coming i'll bet the house on
that and if i'm wrong i'll be blown away
but no i mean this is different level of
talent so it's exciting to see where her
career goes she's only 19 so she's got a
long long career ahead of her so that's
really exciting and she's going to be
wednesday adams and the wednesday show
netflix i'm excited for that too and
brittany snow was just great here as
well and then also great was kid cudi so
the acting all around was just awesome
and the directing right with ty west
he's great at cinematography he's great
at building tension and suspense i
really really enjoyed the first about 40
minutes almost the most actually i
thought there was this eeriness to it
about trying to figure out what's going
on interesting stuff happening with
these adult film stars and kind of
seeing where it was going to head and he
was doing a good job at like sprinkling
the old couple in and you're like okay
this is weird what is happening and it
felt you know at points maybe not super
original but other points very original
and i think where that originality comes
in is having it be this old couple these
villains in the with pearl and i like
that pearl had a good motivation you
know that she missed being you know this
beautiful woman being attractive she
missed having just sex on the regular
and now she's seeing it in maxine and i
really love the scene where she looks
into the shed and sees maxine having sex
and doing this and doing her thing and
you know she's envy of that right it's
it's a good motivation for the villain
and i like how they tied it around with
her when she danced when she did her
first kill in this movie and that they
brought that up they did a lot of good
things that they planted and paid off
later perfect example that is even with
the alligator right i loved loved the
shot that was overhead of maxine's
swimming and the alligators following
her
that was memorable to me and to get the
payoff then
of the alligator
eating britney snow's characters head
off my favorite kill of the film that
was incredible i do wish there was
better kills though because in the
slasher the kills really gotta land
i thought most of them were good but
some were a little lazy especially the
death of kid cuddy's character so that
was a little disappointing in my other
disappointments of the film is i did
feel like after the first 30 40 minutes
it slowed down a little too much until
we got to the final act or picked up
again so i think it had a little bit of
pacing issues the movie was about an
hour 45 minutes i actually think he
could have chopped out some of that
middle and made an hour and 30 it might
have felt tighter and more exciting uh
for where it got a little too slow for
my taste but again i thought the music
was really good and one of the hardest
laughs i've actually didn't expect in a
film like this was when we saw that jen
ortega's character is this
catholic good girl who's set up as this
prude character but then she starts
opening up she wants to be in the film
and that she's wearing the underwear
that says you know sunday on it i
thought that was hysterical that was one
of the hardest laughs i had in a while
so props for that and
there was you know such inspiration from
texas chainsaw massacre here and i felt
that and it wasn't as good as texas
chainsaw massacre but that's you know
high standards but it did its good job
of like showing love for those type of
films but making its own different voice
to it again i think there it was so
close to being great i think this is a
good film
um i just felt like maybe i wish there
was something more here something more
that sticks with you that like in the
mind makes you feel hard which that
usually happens with a24 films or
something psychological horror about
this but i think it was kind of going
for that but didn't really land for me
and that aspect like i'm not thinking
about it after i think it's just a fun
time which yes it was meant to be but i
do think it was attempting to kind of
bring that in and it didn't actually
work as well as it should have so that's
where i was a little disappointed but
overall
i really enjoyed this film and it was a
surreal experience you know my mom
loved the movie which was awesome so
that was cool too to see you know that
that was like a twist for me so it's
doing something right you know and
i thought it was really good so i'm
actually going to give this one an 8.1
and i didn't even stay for the post
credits i didn't know there was one so i
watched on youtube so check that out but
before i spoil the post credit scene
please leave but what i'm gonna say is
that if you have seen it it's exciting
that he's gonna do a prequel now with
pearl again played by mia goth but the
younger version of pearl taking place in
1918 that should be sick and he has said
he's thinking about doing a trilogy so
there's a lot of potential for the next
one db even better believe it or not i
think he already wrapped filming it and
he kept it really secret so that's cool
and yeah i think it's definitely you
know if you're someone who watches my
review before you've even seen the movie
and like getting spoiled it's worth it a
trip to the theater for sure if you like
slashers i think it gives you exactly
what you want in that field but i don't
think it's totally changing the game or
groundbreaking or something that's that
memorable but again i think it's
definitely worth it especially for these
performances by the three leading ladies
here so make sure to put this one
definitely on your watch list for sure
and please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter instagram and tick tock
for more of me i'll see you next time